[Musique]
à 49 ans françois morton devient maire
de guyancourt le troisième de ce mandat
après les démissions de françois de
ligné en 2016 et celle de marie
christine le tarnec le 15 avril dernier
une nouvelle personne mais une
continuité dans la politique municipale
elle s'inscrit tout à fait dans la
continuité de mes prédécesseurs et
notamment de même le tarnec nous sommes
à la fois dans une période
il reste un an même un peu moins et il
n'empêche nous avons encore un projet de
ville à clore donc ce sera évidemment ma
priorité
parmi ces projets la rénovation du mail
des saules engagé depuis l'année
dernière
l'ouverture de la résidence
intergénérationnelle au deuxième
semestre 2010 9 ou encore les travaux de
la place du marché pour son élection le
nouveau premier magistrat de la ville a
obtenu 26 voix
de son côté le conseiller municipal
olivier paréja à voter blanc
les gens ont vraiment envie de
participer et aujourd'hui beaucoup de
projets ne sont pas co-construit ne sont
pas sont concertés a posteriori une fois
que le projet déjà démarré et la
deuxième chose c'est l'urgence
climatique en fait on ne voit pas dans
nos collectivités locales que ce soit
guyancourt que ça soit l'agglo
d'inflexion et là il ya vraiment quelque
chose à faire au sein de l'opposition
anika volant et jean-luc ariane n'ont
pas pris part au vote
il ne me paraît pas normal
c'est passation de pouvoir entre amis
qui dure depuis longtemps réguler en
cours à propos des élections municipales
de 2020 françois morton sera présent et
souhaitent y prendre une part active